As the horror genre's reigning Final Girl,
Laurie Strode, played by Jamie Lee Curtis,
exceeds her reputation in the 2018 sequel,
"Halloween." Despite the self-inflicted
isolation of her militaristic lifestyle and the
resulting strained relationships with her family,
Strode is ready for the inevitable
return of Michael Myers.
"Halloween" is the first installment in a trilogy
directed by David Gordon Green. The films are
direct sequels to the original 1978 film of the
same name directed by John Carpenter. The film
became the highest-grossing entry in the Halloween
franchise, making over $250 million worldwide.
According to Entertainment Weekly, co-writer Danny
McBride said they were eager to shoot a sequel,
but wanted to make sure audiences were on board
first. "Halloween" is certified fresh on Rotten
Tomatoes, with many critics and fans agreeing
that it's a welcome change for the franchise.
Now, the much-anticipated
sequel, "Halloween Kills,"
is officially on the horizon, and here’s
everything we know about the film so far.
The initial release date of "Halloween Kills"
was October 16, 2020, but a July 2020 statement
from Green and Carpenter revealed that the
film was delayed because of the pandemic.
Not dissimilar to many other films that
were scheduled to be released in 2020.
"If we release it in October
of this year as planned,
we have to face the reality that the film would be
consumed in a compromised theatrical experience.
After weighing our options, we have chosen to
push the film's theatrical release by one year."
Now, nearly one year later, "Halloween Kills"
is scheduled to premiere at the 17th Venice
International Film Festival on September 8.
It’ll be hitting U.S. theaters on October 15.
Additionally, the release date for "Halloween
Ends" is set for October 14, 2022, meaning we
shouldn't have to endure such a brutal wait
time before seeing the trilogy's final entry.
Of course, Jamie Lee Curtis will be reprising
her iconic role as Laurie Strode, the tormented
babysitter-turned-fighter. The other Strode women
will be returning as well. Judy Greer is back as
Laurie's estranged daughter, Karen, and Andi
Matichak is back as Karen's daughter, Allyson.
Additionally, Michael Myers will be portrayed
by Nick Castle and James Jude Courtney again.
Will Patton and Jibrail Nantambu will also be
reprising their roles from the previous film.
While "Halloween Kills" is naturally pulling
from characters introduced in the 2018 film,
it's also bringing back
characters from the 1978 version.
The young children Laurie babysat in
the original are all grown up now.
Tommy Doyle will be portrayed by Anthony Michael
Hall, while Kyle Richards is reprising her role
as Lindsey Wallace. Nancy Stephens is
reprising her role as Marion Chambers,
a retired nurse. Charles Cyphers is
reprising his role as Leigh Brackett,
the former Haddonfield sheriff
whose daughter was killed by Myers.
In an interview with Empire,
Green and McBride explained that
"Halloween Kills" picks up directly where the
previous film ended. However, while the first
film focused on Laurie's life 40 years after
surviving a brutal killing spree. Green said,
"This is more about the unravelling
of a community into chaos."
The 2018 film ends with Michael Myers trapped and
left for dead in Laurie's flame-engulfed home,
but as fans know, the Captain Kirk-Masked
killer doesn't go down easily. Or at all.
The "Halloween Kills" trailer shows
Myers walking out the front door
and attacking the firefighters before resuming
his reign of terror on the small Midwestern town.
As Myers leaves a trail of bodies leading
to his childhood home where it all began,
the Haddonfield residents rally together to
hunt down the obsessive killer. Laurie leaves
the hospital where she's recovering from
a stab wound and makes a bold declaration.
"Evil dies tonight."
McBride explained to Empire,
"Events in the film bring together a lot of
characters who were in the 1978 film who we didn't
see last time. They gather to try, once and for
all, to take down Michael, to stop this madman."
It's unlikely that Myers will be defeated
in "Halloween Kills," especially considering
that there's one more film to come in
the trilogy, but anything’s possible.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.